[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
on s'attend pour tout amateur
ce ne sera pas
bonal parce que ça la justice qu'on veut
c'est tout ce qu'on veut d'autres quoi
qu'on aura pas la justice sur un peu de
paix
pour brut
je vais vous raconter la sphère adama
traoré c'était il ya quatre ans le 19
juillet 2016 un mardi après midi
ce 19 juillet 2016 vers 19 heures
j'appelle chez moi pour avoir des
nouvelles de mes enfants
hélas ma mère me dit quelque chose assez
troublant qui va me qui l'homme qui va
me lasser tout de suite mais après ça va
aller elle me dit on va à l'hôpital à
damas ferme à l'aise on se rend à
l'hôpital tout de suite et dans la nuit
quelques heures après peut-être deux ou
trois heures après j'ai ma petite soeur
qui m'appelle ampleur et je n'ai pas
écouté j'ai donné le téléphone à ma
collègue sonia et judy écoute écoute ce
qui se passe je sais pas il ya un
problème mais dis moi ce qui se passe
elle prend le téléphone et là elle me
dit ton frère est mort
[Rires]
où
assa traoré c'est la soeur d'adama elle
nous raconte sa version des faits de ce
jour qui a changé sa vie ce jour là
c'était son anniversaire ce jour là il
avait envie de faire un tour de vélo
ce jour là il va mettre une chemise à
fleurs un bermuda un bob et il va aller
se balader et quand ils arrivent dans le
centre-ville de bon
il voit baggy mon petit frère se faire
interpeller par la police sur une
terrasse de café
malheureusement mon frère ces gens là
n'avaient pas son bouclier n'avait pas
son gilet pare balles il n'avait pas ce
qui aurait pu lui sauver la vie
c'est cette pièce d'identité et il va
partir à toute vitesse on ne sait
toujours pas pourquoi pourquoi les
gendarmes lui ont à courir pour eux
après alors qu'il n'y avait pas de
demande d'interpellation ils étaient en
infraction
ils étaient juste en train de faire un
tour de vélo
l'interpellation de mon frère ce jour là
va se faire en deux temps la première
interpellation se fait devant la mairie
de persan beaumont une voix se faire
violenter où elle sait faire tabasser
les gendarmes sont en civil
un individu qu'on connaît va passer et
va penser qu'à la mosson fait agresser
par des hommes va tenter de défendre à
damas et à damas va prendre cette
occasion là pour aller se réfugier dans
un appartement d'une personne qui
connaît et la deuxième interpellation va
se faire à ce moment-là ils endorment
vous rentrez dans cet appartement
et ce jour là mon frère va subir un
plaquage ventrale ce que je vous dis là
ce que les gendarmes ont dit le soir de
la mort de mon petit frère cette
première audition où ils vont dire qu'à
la main a porté le poids de nos trois
corps n a pas apporté plus de 250 kg
[Rires]
quand ils arrivent au près du corps dont
petit frère les pompiers vont nous
apporter des éléments très importants
des pompiers vont nous apporter une
lumière sur les mensonges les gendarmes
qui nous disait auparavant qui lui ont
apporté les premiers soins
ce qui est faux quand il arrive dans
cette cour et gendarmerie à damas a le
ventre contre sol les menottes aux
poignets donc ils n'ont pas pu le mettre
en position pls et lui apporter les
premiers soins
la mort officielle de mon frère est
déclarée à 19h05
les gens vont se rassembler devant la
gendarmerie en disant qu'ils veulent
voir adama traoré aux alentours de 23h
mon petit frère yacouba va bloquer la
porte de la gendarmerie et va voir un
gradés on va dire à ce grade et on veut
voir damas traoré et c'est là que le
gradé va dire à tata et yacouba doubout
en plein milieu de cette cour de
gendarmerie que adama traoré est mort ma
mère a su jeter par terre pas hurler
yacouba pareil on va les sortir les gaz
et gaz et la foule et c'est là que le
combat à damas alors commencer
[Musique]
des foyers infectieux
situé sur plusieurs organes ont été
relevés lors de l'adoption est par
ailleurs le
légiste nous indique qu'il n'y a pas de
lésion
faisant penser à des violences quand le
procureur yves jannin va parler en
déclarant des foyers infectieux et la
maladie cardiaque et adama traoré
nous savons tout de suite qu'il ment et
là on va dire non on va dire que c'est
faux c'est strictement faut et on va
exiger demandé cette deuxième autopsie
qui va sortir quelques jours affaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
notre avocat maître yassine bouzrou va
demander à ce que le procureur yves
jannier soit dessaisi la faire il va
être dessaisi la sphère est muté à
partir de ces déclarations les révoltes
vont était encore plus grande en france
une nouvelle nuit de violences dans le
val d'oise de personnes interpellées des
voitures incendiées
après les 5 interpellations et une
troisième nuit de violences
les habitants de bolu personnes
champagne de toutes les villes
limitrophes vont exprimer leur révolte
[Musique]
la première question qu'on me pose est
est qu'on va me reposer plusieurs fois
que pensez-vous des révoltes est-ce que
vous revendiquez révolte est ce que vous
appeler au calme
mais moi ce que je dis est ce que je
continue à dire encore aujourd'hui
quatre ans après moi c'est pas cette
violence là qui m'intéresse c'est la
première des violences que mon frère a
subi c'est celle là qu'il faut dénoncer
et c'est surtout que la violence appelle
la violence et ceux qui ont apporté la
première violence c'est les gendarmes
donc c'est celle là qui m'intéressent la
deuxième elle me concerne pas tous
veulent connaître les circonstances de
sa mort lors d'une interpellation par
des gendarmes
que savons nous de cette affaire adama
traoré at il été victime d'une bavure
policière comme le pensent ses preuves
la seule chose que nous réaffirmons et
ça avec force c'est que les gendarmes
dans cette affaire n'ont pas usé de
violence contre adama traoré
il s'agissait d'un individu qui a pris
la fuite à trois reprises qu'il fallait
interpellés qui a été interpellé dans
des conditions normales l'interpellation
accompli que adama traoré n'était plus
une victime et un coupable et que les
gendarmes étaient eux les victimes
ils vont inverser les rôles ça fait déjà
quatre ans que brut suit assa traoré
à l'époque j'étais avec elle en route
pour l'une de ses premières
manifestations à paris
[Musique]
tu es
à deux voies
damas
[Musique]
l'espoir
choquette outils vous donne de la force
- christian pimont fiscale elle
représente vraiment
c'est un ami à lui qu'il a écrit un ami
de la famille
un sens vraiment du coeur ça nous touche
même
elle représente bien un truc est une
histoire du 19 juin sur l'ex procureur
des saisies de notre affaire si on est
tous ces mensonges qui aura mené à une
vérité c'est que c'est forcément passer
quelque chose
et c'en est persuadé
et on ira jusqu'au
jusqu'au
alamar jeu
c'est faux
pour adama kamara
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
c'était il ya quatre ans est ce que vous
imaginez que ça allait durer aussi
longtemps
sincèrement non il ya eu un moment donné
où on a eu on a gardé ce petit espoir en
se disant bon la justice va nous donner
ce droit ce droit à la vérité à la
justice dans la mort de mon petit frère
pas une seule fois je me suis dit que
quatre ans après on serait encore là
dans le combat vérité et justice fort à
damas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas tous
le
[Applaudissements]
non qualifiés depuis quatre ans tout ce
système comme machine de guerre une
machine de guerre qui s'est mise en face
de nous qui a créé en nous des soldats
nous sommes devenu soldat manning
depuis quatre ans on a compris que la
justice n'allez pas en tout cas nous
aider et on a compris que la justice m
était du côté des gendarmes
donc depuis quatre ans et c'est vraiment
une bataille d'expertisés entre les
experts mandatés par la justice les
experts indépendants pris par la famille
alors comment est mort adama traoré le
29 mai dernier un rapport médical
disculper les gendarmes aient conclu à
un oedème cardiogénique une fragilité du
coeur mais trois jours plus tard la
famille d'adama traoré publie une contre
expertise indépendante
cette fois pour les médecins c'est le
plaquage ventrale des gendarmes qui
serait à l'origine de la sfic side adama
traoré
[Musique]
à
aujourd'hui je pense que la sphère adama
traoré représentatif d'un très gros mal
être de cette france au niveau de la
jeunesse au niveau de la discrimination
au niveau de la cause raciale au niveau
de la précarité au niveau de la justice
oui
on ne lâchera pas tant que les gendarmes
n'auront pas dans un tribunal
assis dans un box et puisse rendre
compte de leur comportement et de la
mort et du meurtre de mon frère on a tué
en avant l'accueil on nous tue faire on
ne tuera jamais le nom de faire et j'ai
dit que je ferai du mieux du monde
prennent un symbole
le